und der bayerische ministerpräsident
frau bundeskanzlerin ja meine damen und
herren wir haben heute in einer
video-konferenz mit der präsenz der
beiden ministerpräsidenten beraten und
diese beratungen fanden in einer sehr
ernsten lage statt
uns ist allen bewusst dass viele
menschen wahrscheinlich millionen von
menschen heute mit großer erwartung aber
auch mit sorge auf diese beratungen
geschaut haben und bei allem was wir
heute beraten und beschlossen haben
hatten wir natürlich auch immer diese
menschen im blick auf der einen seite
ihre gesundheit aber auch ihre arbeit
und ihre wirtschaftliche situation
ich will bevor ich die beschlüsse im
einzelnen noch erläutere ein wenig
genauer sagen was die derzeitige
pandemie lage so ernst macht es geht
hier darum dass das tempo des virus und
seiner verbreitung besonders hoch ist
wir erleben einen exponentiellen anstieg
der zahlen mit verdopplung zeiten die
sich weiter verkürzt haben heute waren
es zum beispiel doppelt so viele
infektionen neuinfektionen wie vor einer
woche
und so ist es auch bei anderen wichtigen
indikatoren zb bei dem so wichtigen
indikator der auf der intensivstation
behandelten menschen auch hier haben
sich die zahlen in den letzten zehn
tagen verdoppelt und verdoppelt hat sich
auch die zahl der koma patientin die
künstlich beatmet werden müssen und zwar
in den letzten neun tagen das zeigt
eigentlich also die dynamik
desinfektions geschehens und wir können
sagen dass unser gesundheitssystem heute
noch mit dieser herausforderung fertig
wird aber wenn es bei diesem tempo der
infektion bleibt dann kommen wir binnen
wochen an die grenzen der
leistungsfähigkeit des
gesundheitssystems
der verband der intensivmediziner zum
beispiel hat sie hat uns noch einmal auf
die sich zuspitzende situation
hingewiesen und deshalb
ist vollkommen klar wir müssen handeln
und zwar jetzt und zwar müssen wir
handeln um eine akute nationalen
gesundheitsrat notlage zu vermeiden wir
wollen nicht in eine solche nationale
gesundheitsnotfall kommen und dafür
müssen wir maßnahmen ergreifen
das wichtigste instrument ich habe
darüber sehr oft gesprochen
zur eindämmung einer pandemie ist die
nachverfolgung der kontakte jedes
infizierten und genau dieses wichtigste
instrument stellt uns an vielen stellen
nicht mehr zur verfügung weil die
gesundheitsämter an die grenze dessen
gekommen sind was sie nachverfolgen
können
und das bedeutet nichts anderes als dass
infektionsketten nicht mehr unterbrochen
werden können und dass dann die
kontrolle über die ausbreitung des virus
verloren geht und das muss verändert
werden
wir merken dass zum teil auch schon in
verschiedenen bereichen der
infrastruktur dass immer mehr menschen
auch infiziert sind und wir wissen das
geht dann nicht nur an die
leistungsfähigkeit grenze des
gesundheitssystems sondern auch der
gesamten infrastruktur unseres landes
das heißt die kurve muss wieder
abflachen und die zahl der
neuinfektionen muss sich erst
stabilisieren und dann weiter sinken
damit wir die nachverfolgbarkeit und sie
wissen dass wir die bei etwa 50 pro
100000 in sieben tagen neu infizierten
angesetzt haben damit für die
nachvollziehbarkeit der kontakte wieder
herstellen können
wir haben im frühjahr erlebt dass es uns
gelungen ist diese abflachung und diese
senkung der kurse zu schaffen und zwar
vor allem durch die vernunft und
solidarität der menschen durch
staatliches handeln
die kontakte zu reduzieren aber allen
voran durch die bürgerinnen und bürger
und ihre vernunft und ihr solidarisches
handeln
das war der erfolg des relativen erfolgs
in der pandemie das hat uns mit monate
im sommer erlaubt in denen wir uns frei
bewegen konnten wenngleich das virus nie
weg war und wir wissen jetzt wir müssen
die kontakte wieder reduzieren und damit
auch die gefahr der ansteckung
herunterbringen und deshalb brauchen wir
jetzt im monat november
beginnend vom 2 november noch einmal
eine nationale kraftanstrengung eine
befristete kraftanstrengung die wir auf
die zeit des monats november also bis zu
seinem ende terminieren
wir werden in zwei wochen oder nach zwei
wochen des inkrafttretens uns als bund
und länder wieder treffen und uns
anschauen wo wir stehen und
gegebenenfalls auch massnahmen anpassen
und all das dient dem zweck dann im
dezember wieder natürlich weiter unter
corinna bedingungen das öffentliche
leben wieder besser gestalten zu können
so etwa wie wir es heute kennen
es sind harte maßnahmen die wir
verabschiedet haben es sind belastende
maßnahmen es sind maßnahmen für das
gesamte land und wir haben dabei
versucht auch an die politischen
prioritäten zu denken und eine dieser
politischen prioritäten war dass wir
natürlich das wirtschaftsleben so weit
wie möglich intakt halten wollen und auf
dem zum zweiten das was wir sehr oft in
den vergangenen monaten gesagt haben
dass wir alles daran setzen wollen
schulen und kitas auch offen zu halten
möglicherweise und wünschenswerter weise
mit verbesserten hygiene konsistenten
konzepten
das bedeutet im umkehrschluss wir müssen
harte auflagen machen für die
beschränkung von kontakten im privaten
und im freizeitbereich und genau dazu
haben wir heute auch die entsprechenden
beschlüsse gefasst ich will noch einmal
darauf hinweisen weil es oft in der
diskussion auch gesagt wird dass
bestimmte bereiche ja keine treiber der
infektion sein
wir sind heute an einem punkt wo wir
bundesweit im durchschnitt für 75
prozent der infektionen nicht mehr
wissen woher sie kommen
für 25 prozent können das auflisten das
heißt
nicht mehr sagen das konnten wir eine
zeit lang sein man kann nicht mehr sagen
dass ein bestimmter bereich zur
infektion überhaupt nicht frei trägt und
deshalb haben wir dann in einer abwägung
maßnahmen der persönlichen kontakt
reduzierung beschlossen
das bedeutet der aufenthalt in der
öffentlichkeit ist sofort nur mit den
angehörigen des eigenen und eines
weiteren hausstandes erlaubt alles
geltend ab 2 november maximal aber mit
zehn personen aber immer nur aus zwei
haus stellen wir sagen dass auch in
wohnungen sowie privaten einrichtungen
private feiern oder öfter oder auch
feiern auf öffentlichen plätzen
inakzeptabel sind wir werden hier auch
die kontrollen verstärken
wir fordern bürgerinnen und bürger auf
auf private reisen und besucher auch von
verwandten zu verzichten wenn diese
reise nicht unbedingt notwendig sind
das gilt auch für touristische und tages
touristische ausflüge und reisen
übernachtungsangebote im inland werden
nur noch für notwendige und ausdrücklich
nicht touristische zwecke zur verfügung
gestellt wir schränken die
freizeitgestaltung erheblich ein theater
opern konzerthäuser und ähnliche
einrichtungen messer kinos freizeitparks
und sind beispiele schwimmbäder
spaßbäder saunen und themen sie kann das
dann im einzelnen natürlich alles noch
einmal nachlesen veranstaltungen die der
unterhaltung dienen werden untersagt
gastronomiebetriebe bars clubs
diskotheken kneipen und ähnliche
einrichtungen werden geschlossen
ausgenommen ist die lieferung und
abholung mitnahme fähiger speisen und
der betrieb von kantinen
dienstleistungsbetriebe werden
eingeschränkt wir lassen die den groß
und aus einzelhandel mit auflagen zur
hygiene offen und wie schon zu sehr
schulen und kitas gesprochen wollen wir
auch hier die öffnung ermöglichen
wir werden die von den temporären
schliessungen erfassten unternehmen
unternehmen betriebe selbst wenn vereine
und
in richtung mit einer ausserordentlichen
wirtschaftshilfe unterstützen die der
erstattungsbetrag beträgt bis zu 75
prozent für unternehmen mit bis zu 50
mitarbeitern für größere unternehmen
müssen wir entsprechend der maximal
möglichen europarechtlichen regelungen
unterstützen die minister scholz und
altmaier werden noch in dieser woche die
details für diese maßnahmen
hilfsmaßnahmen auch vornehmen wir wollen
die heimarbeit die mobile heimarbeit
sozusagen dort ermöglichen wo immer das
möglich ist um auch hier kontakte zu
verhindern und wir werden natürlich uns
in besonderer weise auch um vulnerable
gruppen in unserer gesellschaft kümmern
will ausdrücklich sagen dass wir weiter
erreichen wollen dass menschen in
senioren- und altersheimen auch besuch
empfangen können
wir haben uns diese maßnahmen sehr gut
überlegt ich weiß dass viele sagen wir
machen wie jene konzepte wir haben uns
vorbereitet das dann sind wichtige und
großartige anstrengungen die wir so ist
es vorgesehen ab dezember ja auch alle
wieder brauchen aber in der
augenblicklichen situation entfalten
diese hygiene konzepte nicht mehr
ausreichend die wirkung die wir brauchen
denn wir müssen aus dem exponentiellen
wachstum raus und deshalb ist das heute
ein schwerer tag auch für politische
entscheidungsträger ich will das
ausdrücklich sagen weil wir wissen was
wir den menschen zumuten
aber wir müssen den weg finden wie wir
sozusagen gesundheit sicherstellen
können in eine nationale
gesundheitsfragen nicht hinein geraten
und auf der anderen seite weitestmöglich
auch das wirtschaftliche leben aufrecht
erhalten und deshalb bin ich sehr
dankbar dass wir nach langen
diskussionen aber jedoch eine
übereinstimmung bekommen haben bei sehr
unterschiedlichen incidents werten in
den einzelnen bundesländern machen alle
mit
und das ist für mich eine sehr gute
nachricht
denn der bürgermeister ja ich weiß dass
ich hier heute sitzt als vorsitzender
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz aber
ich möchte etwas sagen zu beginn als
regierender bürgermeister
das ist mir heute sehr schwer gefallen
diesen beschluss zu tragen und die
letzten tage die vorbereitenden
gespräche die rücksprache mit vielen
kolleginnen und kollegen die intensiven
sitzungen und beratungen auch bei uns
mit den senatsmitgliedern die haben
gezeigt dass das ein schwerer weg ist
jetzt diese beschlüsse umzusetzen
und dass wir alle miteinander auch
wissen was das bedeutet was das für
zumutungen und für einschränkungen für
viele menschen sind die jetzt auf sie
zukommen wir haben alle schon wieder ein
stück normalität auch genossen hier sind
alle gerne auch wieder in konzerte oder
ins theater gegangen oder einkaufen
gegangen haben uns gerne mit freunden
getroffen
und alles das war möglich in den letzten
monaten und natürlich war das auch immer
verbunden mit der hoffnung dass es auf
diesem weg weitergeht was wir jetzt
sehen und was sich ausdrückt in den
beschlüssen die die bundeskanzlerin
gerade vorgestellt hat ist dass es eben
so nicht weiter geht sondern dass wir
wieder an einem punkt sind wo wir harte
maßnahmen miteinander verabreden müssen
und das ist ein harter und bitterer tag
mir geht es so wie allen anderen
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten wir wollen für unser
land das beste für unsere städte das
beste das es den leuten gut geht dass
sie sich wohlfühlen dass arbeitsplätze
geschaffen werden dass es vorangeht und
dafür haben wir in berlin auch in den
letzten jahren viel getan und auch viel
erreicht und es ist auch hart zu sehen
dass vieles davon jetzt in frage
gestellt ist
das muss man ganz klar sagen und
gleichwohl habe ich in den letzten tagen
und auch heute für den weg den wir jetzt
miteinander beschlossen haben geworden
ich habe deswegen dafür geworben dass
trotz aller bedenken die man
möglicherweise hat und trotz dieser
bitteren rückschritte die ich gerade
formuliert habe
doch im mittelpunkt stehen muss dass wir
menschen
helfen müssen helfen wollen dass es
schlichtweg um menschenleben geht das
hier zu retten ist wenn wir jetzt zu
gucken werden wir vielen menschen nicht
helfen können das muss jedem einfach
bewusst sein
ich habe in den letzten tagen einen
intensiven kontakt gehabt auch mit der
berliner charité die ja auch glaube ich
bundesweites das anerkannt die arbeit
die da geleistet wird und die einen
guten überblick hat wie die situation
nicht nur in der stadt ist sondern auch
darüber hinaus auch in anderen
bundesländern und ist ein ganz klares
bild der sich abzeichnet die
intensivbetten werden in berlin jetzt
mindestens wieder so stark genutzt wie
zu beginn der pandemie 4 märz und april
und das ist eindeutig eine entwicklung
nach oben zu sehen einer rasant schnelle
entwicklung
sie kennen diese berliner corona ampel
mit verschiedenen warnsystemen was den
faktor anbelangt die inzidenz und auch
die auslastung der intensivbetten und
wir sind jetzt bei der auslastung der
intensivbetten über zehn prozent das
heißt wir gehen in diesem bereich der
nächsten warnmeldung
und es ist eben nichts abstraktes mehr
wenn man sich das anguckt sondern da
geht es ganz konkret um gesundheit und
um menschenleben und insofern sage ich
dass es angemessen ist in dieser
situation nochmal alle um solidarität zu
bitten und unseren weg jetzt auch
mitzutragen
solidarität gebend auch mit anderen die
gefährdet sind die schon erkrankt sind
die zu den gefährdeten gruppen gehören
die erkranken können solidarität mit
denen um ihre gesundheit und die eigene
gesundheit zu schützen
mir war besonders wichtig dass wir in
unserer beschlussfassung zwei drei dinge
berücksichtigen die aus meiner sicht
auch für unser zusammenleben von
herausragender bedeutung sind
das erste ist dass schulen und kitas
offen bleiben wir müssen und ich sag das
auch aus meiner perspektive wir müssen
und werden alles tun damit schulen und
kitas offen bleiben dazu sind die
unterschiedlichsten maßnahmen
gegebenenfalls erforderlich auch
vielleicht ungewohnt
nicht maßnahmen und flexible
entscheidungen zu treffen sind von der
technischen ausstattung in schulen die
sich schon verändert hat über flexible
unterrichtsform digitale angebote
natürlich die eine rolle spielen mund
nasenschutz alles ideen und
abstandsregeln alles dinge die auch in
der schule mit zu berücksichtigen sind
aber es geht hier nicht nur um einen
bildungsauftrag der zu erfüllen sondern
wir haben auch im märz und april und
monaten danach
ich glaube nicht nur in berlin aber auch
in berlin gesehen was es für dramatische
soziale folgen hat wenn die kinder nicht
in die schule gehen können oder in die
kita
es hat konkrete auswirkungen in den
familien um es klar zu benennen
es sind gewalt übergriffe gegen frauen
und kinder in einer dramatischen zahlen
nach oben gegangen
man muss sich das vor augen halten was
das also auch anrichtet an sozialen
folgen wenn wir in diesen fragen
eingreifen müssen
wenn wir also hier nicht eingreifen
wollen aus den genannten gründen heißt
das ja dass man in anderen bereichen um
so mehr machen muss
auch deswegen kommt es in den bereichen
des sports der kulturveranstaltung der
gastronomie zu harten eingriffen damit
wir diesen herausragend wichtigen teil
des sozialen auftrages auch weiter
erfüllen können ein zweiter punkt war
mir sehr wichtig das war das
unterstützen der wirtschaft auch da
wieder spielt in berlin aber nicht nur
in berlin eine rolle
wir haben in unserem land viele klein
und kleinst selbständige solo
selbständige menschen die mit ihrer
arbeit und ihrer kraft sich selbst
finanzieren in irgendeiner
unternehmensform dass es wichtig diese
menschen nicht aus dem blick zu
verlieren
das sind oft auch die kulturschaffenden
das sind künstlerinnen und künstler aber
nicht nur das sind auch handwerker
dienstleister und wurde und dass wir
gemeinsam sagen konnten bund wie länder
das ist an einer gemeinsamen
kraftanstrengung uns wichtig denjenigen
auch weiter eine perspektive zu bieten
in dieser schwierigen phase in der wir
sind
das glaube ich war von oder ist von ganz
großer bedeutung und denke dass das auch
zwingend erforderlich war
dass wir an dieser stelle diese signale
setzen ich will abschließend noch einmal
sagen es sind harte maßnahmen und harte
einschränkungen die wir jetzt hier
erleben
aber es handelt sich um vier wochen
einige werden jetzt sagen das ist ein
verdammt lange zeit
und da vielleicht sogar dass es zu lange
währt nur einmal sagen ich würde es
nochmal in den zusammenhang stellen
unsere hoffnung ist und es wird auch
bestätigt natürlich durch viele experten
dass wir damit eine chance haben wenn
wir vier wochen lang das was wir jetzt
miteinander beschließen durchhalten wenn
wir das gut gemeinsam und solidarisch
umsätzen auf allen ebenen des
öffentlichen lebens das wir dann eine
chance haben diese dramatische
entwicklung die wir jetzt sehen auch zu
entschärfen dass wir eine chance haben
ähnlich wie im sommer tatsächlich wieder
ein stück sicherheit auch bieten zu
können und gut gemeinsam durch diese
pandemie zu kommen insofern noch einmal
bei der abwägung aller vor und nachteile
und auch vor dem hintergrund dass es mir
wirklich auch ganz persönlich nicht
leicht gefallen ist diesen weg
mitzutragen glaube ich gibt es sehr gute
argumente dass wir uns gemeinsam darauf
verständigt haben herr ministerpräsident
sie haben eine sehr verehrte damen und
herren in der tat ein schwieriger tag
ein tag an den wir uns alle noch lange
erinnern werden und ein tag mit
schwerwiegenden abwägungen aber in
ernsten zeiten muss man auch ernste und
ernsthafte entscheidungen treffen sind
wir ganz ehrlich wir haben das ja schon
länger befürchtet und auch
prognostiziert sind all die prognosen
leider eingetreten die wir seit wochen
gesagt haben wir haben auf die
entwicklung der zahlen hingewiesen auch
die tatsache dass sich unvernunft leiter
stärker aus wird und dass die vielen
vielen die großartig mitmachen jetzt im
grunde genommen auch ein stück weit in
mitleidenschaft gezogen werden von denen
die nicht mitgemacht haben und die
unvernünftig war
wir haben abgewogen wenn es genau
überlegt welche auswirkung hat es was
wir tun kann man noch warten
soll man noch hoffen dass die zahlen
sich vielleicht anders entwickeln aber
mit erschreckender präzision haben sich
all die einschätzungen auch der
führenden wissenschaftler deutschlands
bestätigt dass heute die groß
und forschungsgemeinschaften in
deutschland sich zusammenschließen und
gemeinsam eine erklärung abgeben sein es
ist ernst ist auch ein novum passt genau
in die zeit
wir haben heute abgewogen besser nichts
tun oder konsequent und klar entscheiden
und zwar jetzt
ich finde man muss das tun woran man
glaubt und von dem man überzeugt ist und
ich bin davon überzeugt wie wir alle
heute bei der gemeinsamen entscheiden
dass es besser ist wenn man weiß was zu
tun ist es dann zu tun wenn es am besten
und schnellsten geht als darauf zu
warten und später schwierige
entscheidungen zu treffen
denn je länger wir warten desto
schwieriger wird es die alternative
nichts zu tun oder weniger zu tun
bedeutet am ende vielleicht für die
situation zu kommen dass wir die
entscheidungen in krankenhäusern zu
treffen und über leben und tod
und das ist aus meiner sicht die falsche
ethische weichenstellung wäre es gewesen
es geht darum auch in unserem land
solidarität zu zeigen
nicht nur wenn es um die frage geht wie
viel freiheit hatte einzelnen sondern
auch wie viel schutz bietet unsere
gemeinschaft eigentlich denen die
besonders betroffen sind
wir sind eine solidaritäts gesellschaft
und kein ego land es geht es auch nicht
bei den maßnahmen um loyalität zum staat
um obrigkeitshörigkeit sondern um ein
gemeinschaftsgefühl was wir alle für
unsere gemeinschaft schaffen können wir
haben festgestellt das bisher getan
reicht nicht wir müssen mehr tun
die zahlen sind so hoch dass wir uns
auch entscheiden müssen dass wir in die
3d gehen um kontakte zu reduzieren
letztlich ist das das entscheidende
motto kontakte reduzieren und dachte
reduzieren kontakte reduziert und zwar
breitflächig drei viertel aller kontakte
sollen runter wenn man das zum anspruch
nimmt dann muss man bereits richtig
auftreten und das sind ist auch in der
tat so dass ich das ausdrücklich sagen
dass so viele leute zu mühe gegeben
in der kultur in der gastronomie haben
so akribisch genau jene konzepte
verfolgt da noch mal danke schön wie
will auch keiner vor den kopf stoßen
genau die bereiche die sich so
unglaublich viel mühe gegeben haben
aber fakt ist wir sind auf einem level
erreicht wo wir nicht mehr genau
nachvollziehen können nicht nur wer
infiziert ist sondern wo infektionen
stattfinden
und wo sie auch verbreitert werden und
deswegen müssen wir hier den großen
ansatz wählen um zu reagieren
dieser ansatz gilt ist für vier wochen
für den november vier wochen das genau
eine zeit in der wir glauben und hoffen
dass es wird das ist eine bittere pille
aber wie jede therapie wie das
medikament sind wir überzeugt und hoffen
sehr dass es auch eine entsprechende
wirkung hat es scheint kurzfristig hat
ist aber langfristig milder als die
alternativen nichts zu tun und dann eine
endlosschleife uns mit dem thema zu
beschäftigen und das ganze land leiden
zu lassen
übrigens geht es dann nicht wenn die
gesundheitssituation sondern auch um die
wirtschaft wie später die entscheiden
desto schwieriger wird es auch für die
gesamte wirtschaft werden was ich heute
sehr stark fahren das muss ich wirklich
sagen war
wir hatten jetzt schon viele mp cars wir
uns ja schon gewöhnt an die
zusammensetzung und wir hatten häufig
sehr kleinteilige diskussionen fand es
vor ort ein
in dieser schweren zeit ermunterte
signal die entschlossenheit von allen zu
spüren ich würde ich sage das auch in
der jugend zusammenarbeit wird glaube
ich die haben auch gestern schon
telefoniert gehabt bei allen kolleginnen
und kollegen auch dass viele bereit sind
die jetzt vielleicht noch nicht so wohl
incidence zahlen haben wir machen das
mit unternehmen einschränken kauf wir
wissen was wir zum beispiel auch unseren
parlamentariern zumuten und seine
regierungskoalition in dem wir quasi in
diesem gremium entscheiden
das ist ja zunächst mal nicht sehr
demokratisch legitimiert scheint es war
wichtig dass wir morgen die kabinette
gehen in die landtage gehen ich werde es
bei mir am freitag tun und auch noch mal
die zustimmung auch bieten auch von der
breiten parlamentarischen beteiligen um
das ganze zu machen wir machen nicht
einfach eine entscheidung über die köpfe
der menschen hinweg versuchen
tatsächlich mitzunehmen und zwar mit
einer priorität wie angesprochen zur
wirtschaftsschule in kita schule ist uns
ganz entscheidend und wichtig wir dürfen
nicht zulassen dass möglicherweise
weisse corona jahrgänge entstehen mit
kindern mit schülern der schlechtere
ausbildung haben
darum wird wichtig sein schule so lange
wie möglich offen
wenn man aufgrund der infektions soll
eine schule geschlossen wird dann geht
auch der grundsatz je kleiner die kinder
desto später kommt muss eine schule
schließen und je er muss sie auch wieder
geöffnet haben
und mir ist auch ganz wichtig dass
unsere schulbürokratie so flexibel wie
möglich reagiert um auch auf diese
situation angepasst was lehrpläne
prüfung betrifft nicht oft in der kürze
der zeit kindern druck zu machen
sie haben schon ohnehin genügend druck
durch die umstände die außen rum sind
also es ist jetzt eine nicht einfache
zeit
sie verordnete eine vier wochen therapie
wenn man es sagen kann wir hoffen dass
die dosis richtig ist dass es
erfolgreich ist wir bitten auch herzlich
diese vier wochen gemeinschaftlich
durchzustehen
die evaluieren in zwei wochen aber wie
bei jeder therapie nicht zu früh
abbrechen ziehen muss würden wir dürfen
nicht den fehler machen den wir anderswo
öfters zu schön wieder in den anderen
rhythmus zu verfallen
ein letzter punkt wir wollen ja keine
angst verbreiten keine panik machen
keine endzeitstimmung man aber bei aller
schwermut der einladung empfinde will
ich nur sagen es ist ja auch in
optimismus beraten wenn wir das jetzt
gemeinschaftlich gut bewerkstelligen
dann haben wir nicht gute basis um über
den winter zu kommen
das ist keine dauerschleife einen monat
lockdown der übrigens ein milder ist als
der erste und dann wieder und dann noch
einmal um zurück es kommen impfstoffe
sind im gespräch die bald kommen können
also es gibt auch anlass zu optimismus
aber wir müssen aus der jetzigen
entwicklung die dynamik nehmen wir
müssen die kurve abflachen
und dann müssen wir versuchen das ganze
anzugehen und die mehrzahl der
bevölkerung glaub ich spürte schon seit
längerer zeit dass heute ein solcher tag
notwendig ist und solche entscheidungen
und ich denke wenn wir das
gemeinschaftlich schaffen und diese
bewährungsprobe bestehen
dann dürfen wir hinter das auch
gemeinschaftlich darauf stolz dann
deutschland hat er einmal glück dass wir
später dran waren und dann rechtzeitig
entschlossen reagiert hat
wir sind wieder später dran wir sollten
die gunst der stunde auch erneut nutzen
entschlossen zu handeln und das war
heute finde ich ein starker tag für die
politik auch wenn es ein schwerer tag
ein ganz schwerer tag und schwere wochen
für die bevölkerung ist aber meiner
überzeugung
naja die bekommen das hin und wir werden
krone erneut trotzen
wir werden davon bin ich fest überzeugt
corona überstehen es gibt auch ein
morgen- und dass wenn wir das
gemeinschaftlich schaffen können dann
haben wir für unser land und für die
vielen menschen in unserem land
wichtigen dienst getan
die erste frage von jörg blank dpa bitte
frau bundeskanzlerin
es hat ja in der vergangenheit oft dass
ich gezeigt dass gerade gottesdienste zu
ausgangspunkten von infektionsketten
geworden sind warum ist in dem text
nichts zu lesen
mit gottesdiensten umgegangen wird gab
es da einen speziellen grund konnten sie
denn bitte erläutern
dankeschön wir haben zu den
gottesdiensten jetzt keine verschärfung
gemacht weisen aber sehr darauf hin dass
unbedingt die jene regeln eingehalten
werden das haben wir nicht alle fälle
benannt in denen in denen das was heute
geht auch weiter gilt
genau das haben wir nicht getan so wie
wir versucht haben zum beispiel alle
geschäfte offen zu lassen
erschien es uns nicht angemessen und
vergleichbar gottesdienste zu verbieten
wenigstens gibt ein hauptgrund warum
immer gottesdienste und auch
versammlungen demonstration in anders
behandelt werden müssen sondern
verfassungsrechtlichen grund regionsweit
versammlungsfreiheit sind hoch
geschützte güte in unserem unserer
verfassung das sind gilt an der stelle
immer auch die besondere sensibilität
gegenüber diesen freiheit wir sind ja
nicht in einer situation des merkurs
muss man sehen
wir haben die schulen offen die kitas
offen alle läden offen und da wäre es
glaube ich nicht vertretbar gewesen dann
bei gottesdiensten zu machen nico fried
von der süddeutschen
frau bundeskanzlerin im zumindest im
entwurf des textes steht gleich im
ersten satz trotz der maßnahmen die bund
und länder vor zwei wochen vereinbart
haben steigt die zahl der infektionen in
starker dynamik heißt das dass das land
und die bürgerinnen und bürger jetzt den
preis dafür bezahlen dass die
ministerpräsidenten und sie sich vor
zwei wochen nicht aufrichtig weitgehende
maßnahmen einigen konnten ist es jetzt
härter als es gewesen wäre wenn man
damals weitergegangen wäre
und eine zweite frage sie sprachen von
diesem dunkelfeld von 75 prozent glauben
sie dass es als begründung gegenüber
gerade gastronomen und
beherbergungsbetrieben und so weiter
ausreicht dass man sagt wir wissen zwar
nicht dass ihr treibe seit aber die
statistik ist so vage dass man es eben
auch nicht ausschließen kann
zum zweiten habe ich eigentlich gleich
zu beginn antworten es ist in der tat so
dass wir als wir eine geringe
infektionszahlen hatten sehr gut
zuordnen konnten wo hat man sich
infiziert inzwischen ist das virus so
weit verbreitet dass wir davon ausgehen
müssen dass es sie in allen möglichen
kontakten insbesondere auch dort wo man
sich dann gegenüber sitzt am tisch und
beim essen januar die maske erkennbar
nicht tragen kann das dort zu
infektionen kommen kann und es kann eben
überall dazu kommen und das ist ja jetzt
sehr oft gesagt worden es man könne
nicht nachweisen dass die gaststätten
der treiber sind man kann aber bei 75
prozent der fälle sowieso nicht
nachweisen was die treiber sind und wir
müssen auch noch mal anders an die sache
vielleicht herangehen haben wir halt
gesagt und auch markus söder die die
experten haben uns gesagt wir müssen
etwa 75 prozent der kontakte reduzieren
das ist sehr viel
und wenn wir die näher kommen wollen
dann müssen es irgendwo kontakte seien
da haben wir die kontakte eingeschränkt
im privaten umfeld da sind wir
insbesondere auf die bürgerinnen und
bürger angewiesen
und dann haben wir gesagt wo können wir
noch kontakte einschränken und da sind
wir sehr stark in den freizeitbereich
gegangen und in den reisebereich weil
wir eben die politische priorität
sollten kitas und schulen offen zu
halten und deshalb ist es also selbst
wenn es in mehr fällen nachgewiesen
werden könnte wo die infektion entstehen
müssen wir in irgendwelchen bereichen
kontakte reduzieren wenn wir noch länger
warten müssen noch mehr kontakte
reduzieren deshalb ist die ist die
auswahl sehr bewusst getroffen worden
wissen dass das härten mit sich bringt
und wissend dass dort viele hygiene
konzepte entwickelt wurden sowohl im
bereich der kultur als auch im bereich
der gastronomie und dass sich auch viele
menschen sehr verantwortlich verhalten
haben aber in der abwägung wie kommen
wir mit der zahl der kontakte runter
ohne das wirtschaftsleben das schul und
liter leben zu gefährden haben wir uns
so entschieden und wir glauben dass das
auch verhältnismäßig und politisch
wirklich vertretbar ist die frage die
sie als erstes gestellt haben was
bedeutet das dass wir vor zwei wochen
nicht entschieden haben
rein theoretisch ist es richtig dass wir
dann hätten weniger maßnahmen oder
weniger lange maßnahmen machen müssen
auf der anderen seite brauchen wir für
alles auch eine politische akzeptanz und
die situation ist einfach so dass diese
politische akzeptanz vor zwei wochen
nicht so da war selbst wenn man
theoretisch ausrechnen konnte was wird
das bedeuten wenn es so ist hat man die
politische bereitschaft dazu nicht
herstellen könne das liegt nicht nur an
den ministerpräsidenten sie sehen was
jetzt auch an protesten und anwohner um
verständnis dass viele sagen warum ich
und die bin ich getroffen
das wird uns noch sehr beschäftigen auch
gegenüber gerichten muss man sozusagen
evident nachweisen dass das
handlungsnotwendigkeit besteht und
deshalb glaube ich haben wir jetzt den
punkt getroffen an dem sozusagen noch
ein stück spielraum ist oder ich hoffe
wir haben ihn getroffen aber auf der
anderen seite auch das verständnis
wächst bei den menschen dass etwas getan
werden muss und das ist politik das ist
das unterscheidet auch politik von
wissenschaftlich man jetzt sozusagen
ende august gesagt hat guckt man hier
habt ihr die ersten anzeichen eines
exponentiellen wachstums jetzt machen
wir mal eine weile alles reduzieren wir
die kontakte ich glaube nicht dass wir
dafür die bereitschaft bekommen haben
wir sind aber auch die bereitschaft der
bürgerinnen und bürger angewiesen und
gleichzeitig sind wir verpflichtet noch
so rechtzeitig zu handeln dass der
notstand nicht schon da ist und da muss
ich sagen auch gerade alle die die als
experten darüber sprechen wir sollen
nicht nur die infektionszahlen im blick
haben gerade die sind ja diejenigen die
sagen guckt doch auch die intensivbetten
wenn ich jetzt mal auf die belegung der
intensivbetten schauer
wenn ich sehe dass ich das alle zehn
tage verdoppelt und weiß ich habe noch
drei zyklen in die ich sozusagen in
denen ich handeln kann dann bin ich
jetzt verpflichtet wenn die betten
einmal voll sind dann kommen immer noch
infizierte danach weil die belegung der
intensivbetten erst 14 tage oder 20 tage
also jedenfalls eine vielzahl von tage
später erfolgt und so sind wir glaube
ich jetzt in einem punkt vor einerseits
sichtbar ist wir müssen handeln
wir sind verpflichtet und andererseits
wo wir aber auch eine chance haben
menschen mitzunehmen und zu sagen ja
okay das sehen wir jetzt auch dass sich
das in die ungünstige richtung
entwickelt hat
christina diels rheinische post frau
bundeskanzlerin wie schnell können die
schnelltests für altenheime kommen wo
sich ja durch isolation und quarantäne
traumatisierung der bewohner auch schon
zeigen was es eigentlich mit bus und
bahnen die ja voll sind wo die menschen
eng stehen habe ich noch eine frage an
herrn müller
wie passt in diesen bitteren tag der
landesparteitag der spd am samstag und
herr söder macht es ihnen sorge dass die
cdu führungslos in das superwahljahr 21
geht und mit ihnen dann die
kanzlerkandidatur besprechen muss also
die schnelltest stehen zur verfügung
sie sind als medizinprodukte zugelassen
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat eine
test verordnung unterschrieben
im bundesanzeiger veröffentlicht ist
bereits vor zehn zwölf tagen und diese
test verordnung weist die übernahme der
kosten für dieses antigen schnelltests
für bewohner von pflegeheimen und
pflegekräfte und in krankenhäusern und
altenheimen zu
das heißt bis zu einer bestimmten länge
ich glaube dass die zahl nicht im kopf
bis zu einer bestimmten menge hat jeder
den anspruch dass auf einer kasse
erstattet zu bekommen und die stehen den
heimen zur verfügung ich habe gestern
einen pflegegipfel gemacht da muss ich
allerdings sagen dass man auch sehen
muss das müsste ich medizinisches
fachpersonal gemacht werden das heißt
die abnahme eines solchen test es dauert
sicherlich zehn minuten bis eine
viertelstunde also es ist eine schöne
zusätzliche belastung auch für das
medizinische fachpersonal in den heimen
aber es verbessert die möglichkeiten
natürlich erheblich weil die antigen
schnelltest ja nicht ganz so
aussagekräftig sind für die pcr tests
aber für den moment des versuchs sind
wir ihm sehr aussagekräftig und damit
haben wir ein mittel in der hand wie wir
an vielen stellen sowieso etwas mehr
mittel in der hand haben auch wenn wir
noch keinen impfstoff haben und noch
keinen durchschlagendes medikament yavuz
und bahnen wir haben vor einigen
appelliert an die länder auch im
schulbusverkehr nochmal eine
verbesserung zu erzeugen und wir glauben
und das ist ja genau der punkt auch von
der schließung von kultureinrichtungen
und von gaststätten und restaurants
wir glauben dass ich einfach der die
dichte des der benutzung des
öffentlichen personennahverkehrs oder
des fernverkehrs verändert wenn ich
keine touristischen reisen erlaube wenn
ich keine besucher einen tagesausflüge
erlaube wenn ich heim arbeit mache wo
immer das möglich ist wenn ich eben
nicht ins theater fahren wenn ich eben
nicht in die gaststätten fahrer das sind
ja alles genau solche dinge weil wir
dadurch kontakte vermeiden wird es gehen
also davon aus dass sich die intensität
auch im öffentlichen personennahverkehrs
niederschlagen wird
zu den schnelltest möchte ich kurz
hinzufügen dass die jetzt in diesen
tagen in den ländern ankommen und ich
möchte noch mal unterstreichen was die
bundeskanzlerin gerade gesagt hat es
entsteht so ein eindruck ja jeder kann
mal schnell den schnelltest machen
zwischen tür und angel und dann weiß man
ja wo man steht das ist schon etwas was
auch gekonnt werden muss mit dem test
muss man umgehen können der ist sehr
sensibel zu behandeln und ist ein
baustein ein baustein um ein stück mehr
sicherheit zu gewinnen wie ist gerade
die situation vor ort oder bei dem
getesteten aber setzt nicht alle anderen
maßnahmen also insofern freuen wir uns
darüber dass dir zur verfügung stehen
wir werden sie auch entsprechend
einsetzen in den pflegeheimen natürlich
vor allen dingen krankenhäusern polizei
feuerwehr in diesen bereichen kommt er
schnellstmöglich zum einsatz
zu ihrer eigentlichen frage in richtung
berlin
die politik und die parlamente haben
auch einen auftrag und wir müssen auch
tragen können und wir müssen
entscheidungen treffen können die
parlamente tagen mit mehreren hundert
mitgliedern zum teil und wir haben
wahlvorbereitungen auch zu organisieren
bundes und landtagswahlen stehen an
und dafür muss es auch in einem
geordneten verfahren die entsprechenden
entscheidungen geben die entsprechenden
grundlagen dann auch für die wählerinnen
und wähler geschaffen werden
aber natürlich in anbetracht der
beschlusslage heute werden wir auch noch
mal kritisch mit unserem landesparteitag
umgehen ich werde noch heute abend oder
morgen zu einer telefonkonferenz mit dem
landesvorstand einladen und wir werden
darüber beraten ob und wie der parteitag
stattfinden kann
gegebenenfalls gibt es ja auch die
möglichkeit dem parteitag in einer
digitalen form anzubieten um zur
entscheidung zu kommen das muss ich
jetzt allerdings auch mit dem
landesvorstand besprechen es gab ja für
heute wurde jetzt vor diesen stunden die
wir gebraucht haben ja für die
beschlussfassung auch noch keine
rücksprache möglichkeit zu ihrer frage
sieht sein wenn ich das so sagen ich war
nicht der tag wo wir uns mit partei
fragen beschäftigt heute sind so viele
menschen besorgt schauen auf diesen tag
wie wir zu entscheiden haben es gibt so
viel nachfragen zu schicksalen zu
existenzen dass wir uns im moment auch
glaube ich weniger um einzelne partei
fragen kümmern da bin ich um verständnis
aber eines darf ihn auf jeden fall sagen
deutschland jedenfalls war heute und ist
nicht führungslos
und es ist im moment ist entscheidende
wenn die herrschaft der vielleicht mit
reduzierter zahl der fragen und
journalist frau bundeskanzlerin sie
haben die zeitdauer jetzt benannt den
november die wir diese maßnahmen alle
miteinander machen sollen was mir noch
nicht klar ist wenn sie sich in vier
wochen wieder treffen oder auch in zwei
wochen beraten was ist das ziel was soll
geschafft sein ist es die 50er incidents
in ganz deutschland erreicht zu haben
machen wir das fest an der zahl der
intensivbetten an der zahl der
infektionszahlen am mehrwert mir ist
einfach sozusagen die faktische
incidents nicht klar und auch wenn er
selber sagt noch eine frage hätte ich
auch noch eine zweite bitte hier sind
jetzt fragen möglich sie kommunizieren
auch über die regierungserklärung auch
über den podcast und es gibt auch andere
möglichkeiten warum er wegen sie nicht
sie haben das amt und sie haben auch die
umfragewerte sage ich mal noch mehr
bürger formate um auch den bürgern
persönlich ob per video oder analog die
fragen die sie haben und die sind ja
viele auch weiter zu erklären danke ja
ich glaube dass ich verschiedene formate
und takoma bedingungen benutzt habe dazu
können auch andere formate kommen in den
letzten tagen war auch sehr viel arbeit
zu leisten damit wir erst mal zu solchen
beschlussfassung kommen also alles hat
seine zeit würde ich sagen
und was wollen wir erreichen das haben
wir ganz klar gesagt wir wollen die
kontakte wieder nachverfolgbar machen
wir werden die zeit nutzen auch noch mal
die gesundheitsämter aufzustocken
die bundeswehr hat noch potenzial wir
gucken auch beamten aus den bundesdienst
die vielleicht zur verfügung gestellt
werden können die länder werden das
gleiche tun
wir müssen also die nachverfolgung
wieder garantieren und wir wissen das
muss dann um die 50 pro 100000 in sieben
tagen liegen das kann ich jetzt nicht
für jeden einzelnen ort genau sagen aber
so wie wir jetzt im augenblick sind in
diesem sehr stark ansteigenden
kurvenverlauf ja für ganz deutschland
und man sieht ja auch die selber selbst
ländern mit einer niedrigen incident tag
für tag höher steigen so darf es nicht
weitergehen also die sage dieser trend
muss gebrochen werden das ist wie so
eine welle
der wir uns entgegenstemmen müssen und
unser unser punkt ist wir müssen die
kontakte nachverfolgen können wenn wir
das nicht können dann haben wir eine
unkontrollierte ausbreitung des virus
und dann kommen verschiedene punkte an
denen wir nicht mehr hinterherkommen
dann wird werden die test kapazitäten
knapp dann kann man überhaupt nicht mehr
ausreichend testen
dann werden die medikamente knapp wir
haben keine nicht von allen medikamenten
beliebig viele substanzen rem diese wir
zum beispiel ist auf der ganzen welt
gefragt so ist die herstellung ist
relativ kompliziert dann kommen die
intensivbetten also dann kommt wirklich
der gesamte gesundheitliche bereich rena
lehmann osnabrück ja ich habe noch eine
frage sie haben ja de facto ein
bundesweites beherbergungs verbot jetzt
hier mit heute ausgesprochen
was macht sie sicher dass das
verhältnismässig ist und nicht wie die
beherbergungs verbote zuletzt in den
ländern von den gerichten gekippt wird
und noch eine andere frage gelten diese
beschlüsse jetzt bundesweit oder haben
dass man in den nächsten tagen gelten
die beschlüsse jetzt bundesweit oder
müssen wir den nächsten tagen wieder
damit rechnen dass es völlig
unterschiedliche interpretationen dieser
beschlüsse in den bundesländern gibt
einige beschlüsse gelten bundesweit das
haupt gab es ja dieses einverständnis
es gibt das bundesland thüringen wird
das parlament noch befassen das ist
ausdrücklich noch einmal zu protokoll
erklärt alle müssten sich allgemein
verordnung umsetzen da kann man auch
nicht genau aber aber so wie es hier
steht gilt es bundesweit und es ist
natürlich schon ein großer unterschied
zu den beherbergungs verbot weil das
bewerbungs verbot hat ja eine
möglichkeit der touristischen reise
ermöglicht wenn ich einen test hatte und
den vorzeigen konnte jetzt werden
touristische reisen generell unterbunden
und sind nicht mehr möglich das ist
schon ein großer unterschied
ergänzend zu dem thema bundeswehr söder
schon drauf eingegangen wir hatten in
den letzten tagen wirklich einen sehr
intensiven austausch zwischen allen
ministerpräsidenten ministerpräsidenten
mit und ohne kanzleramt wir haben
diverse papiere ausgetauscht
formulierung hin und her gewogen und
jetzt in dieser konferenz die wir hatten
waren wir uns alle einig der besondere
wert dieser maßnahmen liegt auch darin
dass wir sie gemeinsam tragen und dass
wir sie gemeinsam schnell umsetzen
es stimmt dass jeder tag zählt und
dieser verantwortung ist sich jeder
bewusst und wir haben alle noch in
unseren länderparlamenten und
landesregierung etwas zu erklären ich
werde mit meinem sohn auch noch die eine
oder andere diskussion führen müssen
aber alle ministerpräsidenten
ministerpräsidenten habe gesagt dass sie
voll dahinter stehen dafür werben in
diesen beschluss gemeinsam bundesweit
umsetzen wollen ich habe noch zwei frage
auf der liste die nehmen wir noch dran
bitte mit hier einer frage herr strempel
ard vielen dank
die erste frage anhand würde und an
herrn müller wie viel vorlaufzeit
brauchen sie bis sie die gelder zum
beispiel in restaurants wirklich
auszahlen können die jetzt geplant sind
geht es schnell oder wird da in den
ländern paar tage brauchen was ja im
zweifel schlimm sein kann für die
betroffenen restaurants zum beispiel und
die frage an die bundeskanzlerin keine
freizeit keine restaurants das heißt ja
auch dass der handel dann leidet leidet
so war es ja quasi auch im frühjahr wird
im handel dann auch noch mal extra
geholfen was das verfahren angelangt ja
es wird schon ein paar tage dauern das
stimmt aber es war uns auch sehr wichtig
und also sowohl von harald meyer wir
anwendern scholz auch betont worden
wir werden anstehende systeme und
auszahlt das antragsverfahren und
auszahlungsmodalitäten für die
zusätzlichen hilfsmaßnahmen die der bund
zur verfügung stellt sondern wir werden
verfahren verfahren die wir haben die
wir kennen die bekannt sind werden wir
nutzen und werden sie erweitern durch
das was wir heute beschlossen haben
insofern glaube ich es sicher gestellt
dass wir schnellstmöglich auch
unterstützen können
natürlich sagen das programm das jetzt
der punkt an billige bis zu zehn
milliarden euro ist ein wirklich
einmalig gutes angebot das muss man mal
sagen
das bedeutet dass bis zu 75 prozent des
umsatzes vom letzten jahr vom oktober
2009 10 von der studie vom november 2009
das wird so zur 75 prozent des umsatzes
bekommt man und zwar mit einem sehr
einfachen nachweis wenn man sich jetzt
mal überlegt der dürfte dieser umsatz
des letzten jahres deutlich über dem
liegen was jeder im oktober hatte und
keiner darf sie auch täuschen wenn wir
jetzt sagen würden wir lassen die
gastronomie irgendwie offen was ja viele
sich wünschen
die zahlen gehen auch in den letzten
tagen auch deutlich zurück weil viele
leute immer mehr besorgt sind gibt auch
weniger leute in die gastronomie gehen
es ist ja auch nicht so dass die theater
überrannt werden bei hohen steigenden
zahlen halten sich die menschen
unabhängig von der verordnung des
staates automatisch zurück das heißt
dieses programm das ist jetzt gibt und
dass der bund aus lobte sich außerdem
nicht groß ich finde es für alle monat
zehn milliarden zur verfügung zu stellen
das hat es selten in der jüngeren
deutschen wirtschaftsgeschichte gegeben
es geht nicht nur für unternehmen das
gilt auch für einrichtungen im es gilt
für theater beispielsweise und ist auch
komplett für solo selbstständige gemacht
dass des deckels tatsächlich ein ganz
breites spektrum ab von denen die jetzt
in der tat durch diese maßnahmen hat
getroffen sind november nochmal überlegt
vier wochen jetzt zu schwierig aber
diesen ersatz zu bekommen ist glaube ich
also in der relation schon ein sehr
vertretbares und vernünftiges angebot
und der unterschied zum frühjahr
übrigens im frühjahr war der
einzelhandel weitgehend zu das muss man
ausdrücklich sagen da war der
einzelhandel zu und deswegen der
einzelhandel bleibt der großhandel
bleibt übrigens auch keine bänder stehen
irgendwo stehen
das heißt sie haben auch darauf geachtet
beispielsweise in den beschluss das
medizinische dienstleistungen weiter
gemacht werden können alles was vor
einem halben jahr an das war zufall ist
das schon ein differenzierter lockdown
nicht der vergleichsweise und mit einem
ganz anderen wirtschafts hilfsangebot
und zwar auch konzentriert auf die vier
wochen
es sind glaube ich dass das auch ein ein
angebot ist es heute auch all diejenigen
die wirklich schmerzen haben beim thema
gastronomie zumindest eine eine
finanzielle dritte dort genau und wir
sind eben gehen auf die unternehmen
betriebe selbstständige vereine und
einrichtungen ein
die von den temporären schliessungen
erfasst sind das ist der groß und
einzelhandel nicht insofern
konzentrieren sich die hilfen auf die
bereiche wo die temporären schliessungen
da sind da mag es auch manchmal
mittelbare betroffene geben dass wir mit
eingerechnet aber waren wir dann lange
diskutiert aber im grundsatz ist der
handel ja offen und kann genutzt werden
die letzte frage also der es winke
reuters eine frage an die
bundeskanzlerin
sie reden ja morgen auch mit den
europäischen staats- und regierungschefs
nachdem jetzt heute sehr deutliche
entscheidung getroffen wurde wäre es
nicht auch zeit auf europäischer ebene
nicht nur das über die korona lage zu
reden sondern auch beschlüsse zu fassen
vor allem was die grenzgebiete angeht
denn man hat ja gesehen dass dort die
infektionszahlen besonders hoch sind
ja wir haben ja ganz klar geregelt dass
reisen in risikogebiete nicht möglich
sind wenn man nicht auch da eine testung
bringt und deshalb werden wir das
natürlich verstärkt überwachen also
diese regelungen bleiben wir weiter
erhalten
da gibt es ja eine regelung für
touristische reisen und deshalb haben
wir in dem punkt 14 oder 15 ist das
glaube ich dann auch gesagt dass das
stärker kontrolliert werden wird durch
die bundespolizei in absprache mit den
bundesländern und information zum
beispiel der schleierfahndung also hier
wird man in den grenzgebieten auch
besser noch aufpassen
viele unserer viele europäische länder
haben mir selber auch maßnahmen
schon eingeführt oder verstärkten sie
gerade deutschland ist jetzt nicht das
einzige land das so stark betroffen ist
vom virus für pendler wir wollen aber
keine grenzkontrollen überdies über die
grenzkontrollen die zwischen bayern und
österreich hinaus besteht bestehen
darüber hinaus wollen wir keine
grenzkontrollen einführen aber eben
erhöhte wachsamkeit durch
schleierfahnder damit beschließen wir
diese pressekonferenz danken ihm
herzlich einen schönen abend
so wird also die neuen maßnahmen
beschlossen von bundesregierung und den
ministerpräsidentinnen der bundesländer
bei mir sind weiterhin meine kollegin
nicole diekmann im hauptstadtstudio
berlin und mein kollege felix zimmermann
aus der redaktion recht und justiz der
gleich weg muss deswegen die erste frage
mal an felix das sind erst wieder sehr
pauschale regelungen ist das juristisch
haltbar dass man einfach mal dann wieder
dass ein ganzes land in so einen
stillstand kann man nicht sagen aber in
so eine halbe vollbremsung schickt der
pauschalen deswegen weil er jetzt gar
nicht geschaut wird wo ist eigentlich
die krone ins ident von 50 überschritten
weil es eben bundesweit geld das ist
also wirklich soweit sehr eine sehr
intensive maßnahmen der intensiv in
grundrechte eingreift allerdings spricht
eben einiges auch für die rechtmäßigkeit
der ganzen einmal erstmal die begrenzung
das ist eben nur november gilt und dann
nach ihm vorbei ist also gibt's aussicht
darauf dass sich das ändert zum anderen
natürlich dieses argument jetzt handeln
was ich später eben noch viel schlimmer
wird die maßnahmen länger dauern müssen
die einschränkungen stärker wären
das könnte vielleicht auch einige
gerichte überzeugen und letztlich
natürlich auch der aspekt dass eben hier
was getan wird von staatlicher seite
nämlich die angesprochene entschädigung
von 75% des vorjahresmonats
also ich des schwachen corona monats von
letzten monat sondern vom letzten jahr
aber ich hab das auch gerade so ein
bisschen raus gehört glaube ich dass die
bundeskanzlerin schon so ein bisschen
sorge hat oder zumindest mit denkt dass
gerichte ja in den letzten wochen sehr
viele maßnahmen kassiert haben oder
ja dies hatte eben da gab es für die
frage der kollege mit dem beherbergungs
verbot
und der antwortete sie dann ja früher
war das verbot kommt man ja mit dem
negativen corona testern doch mehr
herberg werden aber das ist ja jetzt
sogar noch schlimmer jetzt gibt gar
keine beherbergungs möglichkeit mehr
also noch deutlich mehr
geschäftsreisende genauer aber eben
nicht mehr aus touristischen zwecken
was allerdings bisschen wegfällt ist das
argument dass die gerichte jetzt immer
hatten gesagt haben warum denn
ausgerechnet die beherbergung warum
nicht auch dies dies darf
und jetzt ist einerseits ist ihm vieles
mehr verboten worden so dass diese
vergleiche meine gleichheitsgrundsatz
der angebracht wird dass er nicht mehr
so greift weil eben viel
flächendeckender überall kontakt
beschränkung den stattfinden
das könnte also dazu kommt dass viele
gerichte das durch durchgehen lassen
dass man sehen es gibt ja viele
verwaltungsgericht in vielen
verschiedenen bundesländern da ist
durchaus wahrscheinlich
das ist ein oder andere eben
verschiedene maßnahmen wieder kippen
könnte gut dann stellen wir mal darauf
ein dass wir da in den nächsten tagen
und wochen wasser von höheren werden
wahrscheinlich felix erstmal vielen dank
für deine zeit du musst weiter zu den
kollegen aber ich spreche gerne weiter
in meiner kollegin nicole diekmann ich
fasse aber kurz noch mal kurz zusammen
was dort verkündet wurde in der letzten
im letzten 20 30 minuten und ein hinweis
für die zuschauerinnen auf youtube wir
mussten den jet zu machen weil es
einfach zu doll wurde ich habe ja einmal
schon angedeutet wenn es da nicht zu
einer sachlichen diskussion kommen
sondern nur noch wild und wüsten und her
geht dann müssen wir dann ausschalten
das haben wir leider tun müssen das war
noch einfach sehr viele zuschauer auf
facebook sieht es ehrlich gesagt nicht
viel besser aus aber es ist noch händel
war weil es nicht ganz so viele sind ich
hab mal zusammen was dort gerade gesagt
oder also frau merkel hat vor allem
darauf hingewiesen dass das tempo der
infektion gerade relativ hoch ist dass
die infektionsketten nicht mehr
nachverfolgt werden können
es gibt da die zahl von 75 prozent der
infektionen die nicht mehr nachverfolgt
werden könnten und deswegen muss man das
wiederherstellen das war quasi ist das
ziel die nachverfolgbarkeit der kontakte
wieder herzustellen und das
gesundheitssystem nicht zu überlasten
deswegen gelten ab dem 2 november
folgende regeln bundesweit wir können da
auch ganz gerne mal auf meinen rechner
schalten dann könnt ihr mit lesen
da habe ich mal während der
pressekonferenz
bundesweit aufenthalt von maximal zwei
haus ständen mit zehn personen ich
mach's noch ein bisschen größer so
feiern im öffentlichen raum und den
privaten raum hat bundeskanzlerin merkel
als inakzeptabel bezeichnet auf private
reisen soll verzichtet werden
dann gibt es ein quasi beherbergungs
verbot übernachtungen im inland nur noch
für geschäftliche reisen erlaubt
veranstaltungen die der unterhaltung
dienen werden untersagt das hat sie
tatsächlich so im o ton gesagt
einzelhandel bleibt mit auflagen offenen
schulen und kitas sollen offen bleiben
das sind hier bei dem punkt dann gibt es
eine außerordentliche wirtschaftshilfe
erstattungsbetrag maximal 75 prozent für
unternehmen bis 50 personen
da habe ich ein fragezeichen gemacht was
ist eigentlich mit einzeln unternehmen
und freiberuflern die mobile heim
möglichkeit heimarbeit soll ermöglicht
werden die dann würde ich immer ein
fragezeichen dahinter machen will die
bundesregierung das ermöglichen und es
soll sich um variable gruppen gekümmert
werden zum beispiel mit schnelltests für
heim besucher ein altenheim
gottesdienste wurde auch im chat schon
viel gefragt bleiben erlaubt und es soll
keine grenzkontrollen geben so nicole im
hauptstadtstudio berlin irgendwelche
überraschungen ist dabei überraschend
fand ich dass ich alle tatsächlich doch
geeinigt haben ja also saß ja eigentlich
bis gegen 16.17 uhr heute nicht aus vor
allem bodo ramelow ministerpräsident in
thüringen hatte gestern gesagt er werde
den heute zu erwartenden beschlüsse
nicht zustimmen gibt es eine
protokollerklärung die so hat also
zwischen beschlüsse die der heute
getroffen worden
da macht thüringen auch noch einmal ganz
klar dass man möchte dass der wie wir
das hier genannt lass mich nachsehen
eine akute nationale gesundheitsnotfall
soll vom deutschen bundestag
festgestellt werden
man wünscht sich eine höhere
legitimation dafür dass solche
beschlüsse wie heute auch wenn die dann
ja in den ländern noch mal umgesetzt
werden müssen
von den ministerpräsidentinnen getroffen
werden also so ganz wohl fühlt sich
thüringen mit diesem prozedere nicht
mehr dafür daraus klar hervor
wissenschaftliche untermauerung der
notwendigkeit der beschlossenen
maßnahmen aber erst mal wurde ja auch
eben noch mal auf nachfrage von merkel
ganz klar gesagt ist das jetzt eine
bundesweite regelung und danach saß
gestern nicht aus denn zum beispiel auf
deren günther ministerpräsident in
schleswig holstein hatte sich gestern
noch gegen das runterfahren komplett
herunterfahren der gastronomie
ausgesprochen und das komplett der
faktor so ich muss noch mal kurz auf den
live chat reagieren die call bevor wir
jetzt wieder nochmal zu den sachlichen
themen kommen hier kommt dass der
vorfall von volker herbert auf facebook
wir hätten nur angst kritische fragen
beantworten zu müssen nein herr brand
haben wir nicht aber wenn sie mal
einfach über sich darüber gucken da
schreibt ein user namens bionik for life
etwas mit ihr wie sternchen sternchen
sternchen das möchte ich mir ersparen
und wenn wir den schritt zu machen
können müssen dann liegt das am genau
solchen kommentaren wie von bionik for
life dann könnt ihr euch bei denen
bedanken weil sowas wollen und können
wir nicht dulden so ansage von mir du
hast ganz schon erklärt das thüringer
parlament soll befragt werden das heißt
die haben echt noch mal die chance das
ganze jetzt für thüringen zu kippen
naja also alle landesparlamente haben
die chance zu kippen ja es gibt das
infektionsschutzgesetz und das gibt vor
dass die länder zuständig sind die
mädchen hat gesagt wir fragen auch das
parlament nicht die anderen haben das
jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen hören dass
er damit auch noch mal in das allgemeine
spitzen ich habe versucht zuzuhören aber
thema
ich weiß dass man im studio ich höre ja
gerade was da los ist um gottes willen
hier verliert sich auch noch miteinander
nein aber also es war ja gerade zu hören
auch markus söder sieht das war und man
hat ja auch sehr oft vor allem auch
markus söder betont es geht jetzt erst
mal um vier wochen
das heißt ja man weiß dass dass man das
jetzt nicht ewig so durchziehen kann und
dass die akzeptanz eben sinken kann
und um diese akzeptanz auch aufrecht zu
erhalten wir haben das ja vor der
pressekonferenz auch schon gesagt die
umfragen sagen ja ganz klar
dass ein großteil der deutschen immer
noch hinter diesen massnahmen steht
nicht den jetzt beschlossenen aber denen
davor um diese akzeptanz aufrecht zu
erhalten ist es eben auch wichtig
parlament einzubinden so ich guck mal
hier wir haben nämlich als bevor der
chat auf youtube zu gemacht werden
musste von uns viele fragen gesammelt
weil die gab es natürlich auch eine
frage kam auch warum wir keinen
mundschutz hier im studio tragen ganz
einfach weil wir dann doch den
sicherheitsabstand eingehalten haben die
da sind hier in einer sehr großen
redaktion wir haben eine tür die ihr
nicht sehen könnt dies offen da wird
belüftet und nicole ist alleine im büro
von daher müssen wir das nicht und es
würde auch echt schwierig sein mit dem
toni wenn ich mal hier in unser
gemeinsames dokument gucke was wir da
haben also zu den neuen maßnahmen gibt
es folgende kommentare auf youtube von
wer weiß die maßnahmen sind überzogen
alle unter 55 sind nicht wirklich
gefährdet warum müssen die jungen leute
das mitmachen
silvia schwuler schullehrer sagte der
erste doktor hat auch nichts gebracht
das virus ist noch da ich glaube da kann
man sagen der hat doch was gebracht das
kann in den kurven sehen aber das ist
hier aus davon weg gehen würde war
glaube ich auch nie ziel und auch geht
gar nicht dann gibt es fragen in
richtung wird es in zukunft stärkere
strafen oder wird da kann gegen korona
leugner vorgegangen dazu habe ich nichts
gehört durchsetzung der aktuellen regeln
massen pflicht habe doch nirgendwo
durchgesetzt schreibt 11 123 habe ich
auch nichts zu gehören die kultur
stärkere kontrollen dass das ist ja und
dann geht es hier in die einzelnen
unterpunkte schließungen tourismus
gastronomie arbeit und die schule kinder
alte familienfeiern kirchen weihnachten
sport also es ist ziemlich viel ich
versuche das mal so ein ganz klein
bisschen anzureißen weil sonst wenn wir
alle fragen beantworten sitzen wir in
zwei stunden noch hier
ich gehe mal hierdurch also wir hatten
vor allem schließt der einzelhandel nein
können wir sagen tourismus bleiben die
grenzen offen für den internationalen
reiseverkehr auf beiden seiten da hat
sie gar etwas noch mal am ende gesagt
kaum erkennen
es wird keine grenzkontrollen geben
das hat sie gesagt da ging es vor allem
um die
die schleierfahndung was ist dann damit
dann gemeint genau schleierfahndung also
was sie war sogar zu büro ist ja eben
gegen es gibt ja klare ansagen darüber
was es bedeutet in risikogebiete zu
reisen
und genau also man die pendler davon
ausnehmen aber tourismus ist ja jetzt
also wenn man jetzt alles heute
zusammenfasst diese pressekonferenz ist
jetzt überhaupt nicht die zeit für
tourismus wird jetzt ich kann reist das
ist jetzt auch ein großes thema hier was
auch noch abgefragt wird da gucken wir
mal ganz kurz raus rein verreisen mit
einem zweiten wohnsitz in ein anderes
bundesland wie verhält es sich damit
ich habe nur gehört oder ist das war das
ab ist der appell der bundesregierung
dass man sich auch möglichst nichts
bewegen soll sondern möglichst in seinem
einen wohnort bleiben aber eine richtige
regelung gibt es dann nicht mehr
ist ja auch nur ein appell na also
abgesehen von den hotels und pensionen
und was ist da gibt also man darf nicht
mehr beherbergt werden
ein bundesweites beherbergungs verboten
hatte dass eine kollegin eben bei der
pressekonferenz
wenn man aus touristischen gründen oder
das ist auch noch mal wichtig aus nicht
verzichtbaren gründen reist also ich
glaube wenn ich jetzt einen nahen
familienangehörigen karriere und zur
beerdigung reisen muss in das bundesland
dann könnte das zb das wird noch
interessant seien in den nächsten wochen
aber so war es auch bisher so war es
auch während des beherbergungs verbotes
dann darf ich schon in dem hotel
unterkommen ansonsten gibt es eben den
appell die bürger innen sind aufgerufen
alles zu vermeiden was zu vermeiden ist
also 75 prozent der kontakte sollen
reduziert werden so sagte es eben
ministerpräsident söder und das bedeutet
für mein dafürhalten auch wenn es nicht
vermeiden lässt auch nicht eine
zweitwohnung in einem anderen bundesland
so besuchen es sei denn wie gesagt man
hat hat eine notlage
eine frage noch dann machen wir den
livestream für heute erstmal zu
zumindest diesen kam immer wieder was
ist mit den unis also schulen und kitas
haben wir gehört sollen offen bleiben
aber fast
sie täten und meinen prüfungen witz da
irgendwie regelungen geben da
diesbezüglich habe ich als ich zugehört
habe nichts gehört du als ich so gehört
habe habe ich auch nichts gehört und ich
bin auch dieses papier durchgegangen das
jetzt rum geschickt wurde mit den
beschlüssen bekommen universitäten nicht
vor das thema hat man heute ganz
offensichtlich nicht verhandeln ok dann
wird es wahrscheinlich darauf
hinauslaufen dass jede uni das selber
irgendwie für sich regeln
nicole vielen dank bis hierhin für deine
zeit für deine aufmerksames zuhören
während der pressekonferenz für deine
antworten und euch auch fürs mitmachen
für eure sachlichen fragen
die gab es ja auch zum glück dass wir
den chat noch mal zu machen müssen wird
hoffentlich nicht so häufig vorkommen
aber ist halt die letzte reißleine die
wir hier haben trotzdem bedanke ich
nicht dafür dass er dabei gewesen seid
und sagt bis zum nächsten mal macht gut
und tschüss